you're not the only one in your family
that's got a film coming out this
holiday season your dad landed a film
and licorice pizza
pizza might have seen it how did it
happen i haven't seen it yet but my dad
george dicaprio has a cameo in a paul
thomas anderson movie
today was a good day i know he's playing
a water bed salesman right that's right
in real life he sold water beds
unbelievable
here now
there you go
your breathing is stressing me out this
will affect the entire planet i know but
it's like so stressful we know that
you've always been passionate about the
fight against climate change so how much
so did that to the premise of this film
hey i got to sign on to this project
absolutely everything to be honest i
mean i'd been looking for a film that
could
articulate the urgency of the climate
crisis but you know when you're talking
about an issue like that that people in
a lot of ways feel disconnected from it
is something that evolves slowly from a
narrative perspective how do you create
tension and urgency and adam really
cracked the code with this movie he made
it about a comet hitting planet earth
within eight months and how we as a
society how the media
all deal with you know this sense of
urgency and it was a stroke of genius
for him to be able to do a dark comedy
similar to dr strange love about the
climax crisis but put it in this context
one minute you're laughing at the film
the next it's like whoa like i said it's
a dark comedy but then it takes a real
serious turn at the end of the end of
the film and has a real powerful message
that i hope people will listen to and
the caliber of this cast is next level
it is out of this world did you look
you're top notch yourself leo but was
there anyone in particular that you're
like
i'm having this moment i'm a little
awestruck here i think as soon as a
young woman by the name of meryl streep
walked on to set i had i got to work
with her almost 30 years ago in a film
called marvin's room but when she came
in as the president i mean all of us
were on our toes ready to improvise
fully prepared because she's just a
marvel and mark rylance too getting to
work with him and of course
my old buddy jonah too